Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Silvina Katz
En agosto de 1947,
India obtiene su independencia
después de 200 años
de régimen británico.
A continuación ocurrió
una de las migraciones
más largas y sangrientas de la historia.
Se estima que un millón
de personas perdieron la vida.
Antes de la colonización británica,
el subcontinente indio era
un mosaico de reinos regionales
conocidos como principados
habitados por hindúes, musulmanes,
siks, jainistas, budistas,
cristianos, parsis y judíos.
Cada principado tenía
sus propias tradiciones,
tipos de castas y liderazgo.
Al inicio de los 1500, una serie
de fuerzas europeas colonizaron India
con asentamientos
comerciales costeros.
Para mediados del siglo XVIII,
la English East India Company
emergía como la fuerza
colonial primaria en la India.
Los británicos gobernaron
algunas provincias directamente
y los principados indirectamente.
Bajo la régimen indirecto,
los principados mantenían soberanía,
pero debían dar concesiones políticas
y financieras a los británicos.
En el siglo XIX, los británicos
empezaron a clasificar
a los indios por su identidad religiosa,
una burda simplificación
de las comunidades indias.
Consideraron a
los hindúes como “mayoría”
y todas las otras comunidades religiosas
como “minorías” diferentes
siendo los musulmanes
la minoría más grande.
Los sijs eran considerados
parte de la comunidad hindú
por todos menos ellos.
En las elecciones, la gente podía
sólo votar por candidatos
de su propia identidad religiosa.
Estas prácticas acentuaron
las diferencias,
que sembraron desconfianza entre
comunidades que antes coexistían.
El siglo XX arrancó con décadas
de movimientos anticoloniales,
donde los indios pelearon
para independizarse de los británicos.
Tras el fin de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial,
bajos enorme presión financiera
después de la guerra,
los británicos finalmente cedieron.
Los líderes políticos indios
tuvieron visiones diferentes
de cómo debía ser
una India independiente.
Mohandas Gandhi y Jawaharlel Nehru
representaban a la mayoría hindú
y querían una India unida.
Muhammed Ali Jinnah,
quien lidereaba a la minoría musulmán,
creía que las heridas creadas
por la colonización no tenían reparación.
Jinnah alegaba por
una división en dos naciones,
una donde el hogar de los musulmanes
se llamaría Pakistán.
Después de disturbios en 1946 y 47,
los británicos apuraron su retirada
y planearon la independencia
india a puerta cerrada.
En junio de 1947,
el virrey británico anunció
que India obtendría
su independencia en agosto,
y sería divida en India hindú
y Pakistán musulmán,
sin dar buena explicación
de cómo ocurriría.
Con base en mapas viejos,
censos incorrectos
y conocimiento somero del territorio,
en apenas 5 semanas, el Comité
de Límites delineó la frontera
que divide a tres provincias
bajo la regla directa británica:
Bengala, Punjab y Assam.
La frontera considera donde
los hindúes y musulmanes son mayoría,
además de factores como
ubicación y porcentajes de población.
Si un área de mayoría hindú
tenía frontera con otra igual,
se incluía en la India;
pero si el área de mayoría hindú
tenía frontera con una mayoría musulmana,
se hacía parte de Pakistán.
Los principados en la frontera debían
elegir con cuál de las nuevas naciones
se quedaban perdiendo
su soberancia en el camino.
Mientra el Comité de Límites
trabajaba en el nuevo mapa,
hindús y musulmanes empezaron
su mudanza a las áreas
donde creían que serían
parte de una mayoría religiosa,
pero no podían estar seguros.
Las familias se dividieron.
Ante el temor a la violencia sexual,
los padres enviaron
a sus hijas y esposas a regiones
que se percibían seguras.
El nuevo mapa no fue revelado hasta
el 17 de agosto de 1947,
dos días después de la independencia.
Las provincias de Punjab
y Bengala se convirtieron
en las geográficamente separadas
Pakistán Oriental y Occidental.
El resto se convirtió
en India de mayoría hindú.
En un periodo de dos años, millones
de hindúes y sijs que vivían en Pakistán
abandonaron India,
mientras que los musulmanes
en India huyeron de lugares
donde sus familias
habían vivido por siglos.
Las ciudades de Lahore, Delhi,
Calcuta, Dhaka y Karachi
se vaciaron de antiguos residentes
y se llenaron de refugiados.
En el vacío de poder que dejaron
las fuerzas británicas,
milicias radicales y grupos locales
masacraron migrantes.
Mucha de la violencia ocurrió en Punjab
y las mujeres se llevaron la peor parte
sufriendo violación y mutilaciones.
Casi 100 000 mujeres
fueron secuestradas
y obligadas a casarse con sus captores.
Los problemas creados por la Partición
llegaron más allá de esta secuela mortal.
Muchas familias que
se mudaron temporalmente,
quedaron desplazadas permanentemente
y las fronteras siguieron en disputa.
En 1971, Pakistán del este se separó
para convertirse en
el nuevo país de Bangladés.
Mientras tanto, el gobernante hindú
de Kashmir decidió unirse a India,
una decisión que se concretó
con un referéndum público
de una población de mayoría musulmana.
Este referéndum sigue
sin suceder al 2020,
India y Pakistán siguen peleando
por el Kashmir desde 1947.
Más de 70 años después,
el legado de la Partición
sigue clara en el subcontinente:
en sus nuevas formaciones políticas
y en la memoria de la familias divididas.